Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is, the rest is history.com. Some years since, the feet of walking 1,000,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 the restishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。也就是说，the rest is history.com。若干年前，步行1,000英里的壮举，
Miles in 1,000 hours was considered next to an impossibility. But here, we have to record the Wander doubled. This has been accomplished on the Surrey Cricket Ground, Kennington Oval, by Richard Manx, whose feats of walking present instances of the capability and endurance of the human frame altogether unparalleled. Manx commenced this feat on Friday the 26th of last September, but, being suddenly attacked with diarrhea, he was compelled to give up on the Monday following after having walked 129 miles. His surgeon ordered Manx to rest for a time, to recruit his health and strength. This the pedestrian reluctantly yielded to, and for a fortnight he remained under
在1,000小时内走完被认为近乎不可能。但在这里，我们不得不记录下这一纪录的翻倍。这一壮举是在萨里板球场，即肯宁顿椭圆球场，由理查德·曼克斯完成的，他的步行壮举展现了人类身体完全无与伦比的能力与耐力。曼克斯于去年9月26日星期五开始这项壮举，但由于突然遭到腹泻袭击，他被迫在随后的星期一放弃，当时他已经走了129英里。他的外科医生命令曼克斯休息一段时间，以恢复他的健康和体力。这位步行者不情愿地服从了，并在
medical treatment. On Friday the 10th of October, he recommenced his great task, starting for the first mile at 4 o'clock in the afternoon, on he went, full of spirit, completing his first 100 miles at 43 minutes, 15 seconds after 5 o'clock on Sunday evening the 12th of October, his second 100 miles at 44 minutes, 10 seconds past 7 o'clock on Tuesday the 14th of October, and finally, after completing another 799 miles, going for his thousandth mile at half past 11, 11, o'clock on Friday morning, October the 31st. Manx has been heard to declare that never again will he attempt such a frightful feat. So that was the Illustrated London News, November 1851.
医疗护理下度过了两周。10月10日星期五，他重新开始了伟大的任务，于下午4点开始了第一英里的征程，他一路精神饱满，在10月12日星期日晚上5点43分15秒完成了他的前100英里，在10月14日星期二晚上7点44分10秒完成了他的第二个100英里，最后，在完成了另外799英里后，他在10月31日星期五上午11点半迎向他的第一千英里。据听到曼克斯宣称，他再也不会尝试这样可怕的壮举了。这就是《伦敦新闻画报》，1851年11月。
And Tom, it is recording one of the supreme feats in the history of sport, a triumph over adversity, over adverse conditions, over their landscape, and over diarrhea, it's a feat that deserves to live in the legends of sport, but sadly, has been almost completely forgotten. Tragically, it has. And I like to think that the rest of history is nothing, if not a vehicle for resurrecting great sporting feats that have been forgotten. And I think obviously one of the reasons why it's been forgotten is it did happen a very long time ago.
汤姆，这记录了体育史上最崇高的壮举之一，是对逆境、恶劣条件、地形以及腹泻的胜利，这是一项值得永载体育史册的壮举，但遗憾的是，它几乎已被完全遗忘。悲惨的是，确实如此。我喜欢认为，《历史的余烬》若不是复活那些被遗忘的伟大体育壮举的载体，那就毫无意义了。而且我认为，显然它被遗忘的原因之一是它发生的时间确实非常久远。
So it happened before the first Olympics of the modern era in Athens, in 1896, before. for the establishment here in England of the Football League in 1888, before the founding of professional baseball in the United States way back in 1869. So, I mean, that's a very good reason why Richard Manx is no longer a household name. But I guess it's also because the sporting field in which he established himself as the goat, the greatest of all time, namely pedestrianism. I mean, it no longer exists. Nobody, you don't see pedestrianism on Sky Sports.
所以它发生在1896年雅典现代奥运会之前，发生在1888年英格兰足球联赛成立之前，早在1869年美国职业棒球创立之前。所以，我的意思是，这就是理查德·曼克斯不再是个家喻户晓的名字的绝佳理由。但我想这也是因为他将自己确立为 GOAT（历史最佳）的体育领域，也就是步行赛。我的意思是，它已经不复存在了。没有人，你在天空体育上看不到步行赛。
No, no, but people still walk. They do. But they're not doing it as part of a very complicated sporting infrastructure, are they? No, they're not. And in that, it's unlike other sports that were starting to flourish in the early 19th century in Britain. So horse racing, I mean, that's been going on for a long time. Cricket, that dates back to the 17th century. Boxing, again, in very long history. But sadly, pedestrianism hasn't made it into the modern era. So it might in that sense seem a kind of historical artifact. But I think the reason for zooming in on this seemingly obscure topic is that his incredible feat at the Kennington Oval in 1851, even as it reminds us of a sporting world that we have lost, I think it is also anticipating the future. And you can see lots of ways in which it anticipates the future in that report that you read from the Illustrated London News.
不，不，但人们仍然在走路。他们确实在走。但他们并非作为非常复杂的体育基础设施的一部分在进行，对吧？不，他们不是。正因如此，它不同于19世纪初在英国开始蓬勃发展的其他体育项目。比如赛马，我的意思是，那已经进行了很长时间。板球，可以追溯到17世纪。拳击，同样有着非常悠久的历史。但遗憾的是，步行赛未能进入现代。因此，从某种意义上说，它可能看起来像是一种历史文物。但我认为，之所以将镜头对准这个看似冷门的话题，是因为他在1851年肯宁顿椭圆球场的惊人壮举，在让我们想起那个已经失去的体育世界的同时，我认为它也预示了未来。你可以从你刚才读到的那篇《伦敦新闻画报》的报道中，看到许多预示未来的方式。
So the fact that the report exists at all, right? So we did a story, lots of listeners will remember one of the great episodes we did on history's greatest monkeys. And we covered another sporting fixture, which was the encounter between Jacko McCacco and Puss, the dog in the Westminster Pit. And that was a window into the unknowability of the past because there weren't really reliable newspaper reports of what happened in this great sporting encounter. But here, you know, we have a very detailed report with very, very precise timings. Yes, perhaps overly. size. Yes, exactly. 43 minutes and 15 seconds after 5 o'clock. But the thing is, that's what people love in sport, isn't it? Of course it is. The statistics plus the media, plus the
所以，这篇报道本身能够存在这一事实，对吧？我们曾讲过一个故事，很多听众会记得我们做过的关于历史上最伟大猴子的精彩剧集之一。我们报道了另一场体育赛事，也就是威斯敏斯特斗兽场中杰科·马卡科与狗“普斯”的对决。那是了解过去不可知性的一扇窗，因为对于这场伟大的体育对决中发生的事情，并没有真正可靠的报纸报道。但在这里，你知道的，我们有一份非常详细的报道，里面有非常非常精确的时间。是的，也许过于精确了。是的，正好。下午5点43分15秒。但问题是，这正是人们在体育中所喜爱的，不是吗？当然是的。统计数据加上媒体，再加上
reportage, that's key to the sporting phenomenon, isn't it? It absolutely is. And also, I think the other thing that points to the future is the way that innovations have been introduced at this great sporting occasion to boost attendance, to get spectators in through the turnstiles. So one of these is reported, not in the Illustrated London News, but in another paper covering this occasion, the morning advertiser. And the journalist writes, a number of variegated lamps have been placed in the most conspicuous parts of the course, and one placed on each of the stakes that hold the ropes that form the ring. And these are set up on the final night where Manx is approaching the finishing line, because so many people want to come and see it. And obviously he's walking through
报道，这才是体育现象的关键，不是吗？绝对是。而且我认为，另一个指向未来的事情是，在这场伟大的体育盛会上引入了各种创新，以提高上座率，吸引观众通过旋转门进场。其中一项报道并非在《伦敦新闻画报》上，而是在另一份报道这一盛事的报纸《晨报》上。这位记者写道：“在赛道最显眼的地方安放了许多彩色灯笼，在构成环形绳索的每根桩子上也各安放了一个。”这些是在曼克斯接近终点线的最后一晚设置的，因为有太多人想来看这个。而且很显然，他是在深夜步行。
the night. Yeah. And it's dark. I'm just going to just go on record here. People say there's no such thing as progress in history, but a world in which people would get up in the middle of the night, to watch a man basically walking down the road, is lamented. Absolutely. I mean, it is progress because, to quote the sports journalist Dominic Utton, who's written a fascinating article on this, these lamps made Max's display of pedestrianism on the final night of his great feet at the Oval, the world's first floodlit sporting event. Wow. And all of this contributes to the buzz. Yeah. So by the time that Manx finally gets to cross, the finishing line. The Oval is absolutely full to capacity. All 3,000 seats, 3,000 seats. Incredible.
对。而且天很黑。我要在这里正式记录一下。人们说历史没有进步这种事，但一个人们会大半夜起床去看一个男人基本上在路上走路的世界，却被哀叹。绝对的。我的意思是，这确实是进步，因为引用体育记者多米尼克·阿顿的话说，他写了一篇关于此事的迷人文章，正是这些灯笼让曼克斯在椭圆球场伟大壮举的最后一晚展现的步行赛，成为了世界上第一场有泛光灯照明的体育赛事。哇。所有这一切都营造了轰动效应。所以，当曼克斯终于穿过终点线时。椭圆球场已经完全座无虚席。全部3,000个座位，3,000个座位。太不可思议了。
And there are massive, massive queues outside. All the streets around the Oval are kind of filled to overflowing. It's the talk of London. I can't help thinking that a lot of those people are going to be disappointed. But they're not, though. I mean, that's the thing. The sense of occasion is incredible. And I think that's precisely what makes it such a kind of pivotal moment in the history of sport, that it's midway between the future, a future with floodlight sporting occasions and press coverage and all of that, but also a pass that reaches way, way back into the pre-modern world. And I know you're passionate about this particular sporting venue. So the Oval in itself is a harbinger of what's to come, isn't it? Because it's the ancestor in some ways, it was an ancestor
外面还有大量、大量的排队人群。椭圆球场周围的所有街道都挤得水泄不通。这是伦敦的街谈巷议。我不禁在想，那些人中有很多会感到失望。但他们并没有，真的。我的意思是，这就是重点。这种盛会的感觉是不可思议的。我认为这正是它成为体育史上如此关键时刻的原因，它介于未来——一个拥有泛光灯体育赛事和新闻报道等一切的未来——与一个深深追溯到前现代世界的过去之间。我知道你对这个特定的体育场馆充满热情。所以椭圆球场本身就是未来的先兆，不是吗？因为它在某种程度上是祖先，它是
of the sports stadiums, you know, Villa Park, Molyneux, the great stadiums of football or crickets or American football or baseball or whatever it might be. Yeah. So the Oval had been founded six years earlier in 1845 in Kennington, which is in South London. And it's catering to the southern reaches of London, which by this point is the world's largest city, in the same way that another and even older cricket ground, namely lords, caters to its northern reaches. And these two grounds are physical emblems of sport.
体育场的祖先，你知道的，维拉公园球场、莫利纽球场，那些足球、板球、美式橄榄球或棒球等等伟大的体育场。所以椭圆球场是在六年前的1845年建立在伦敦南部的肯宁顿的。它迎合了伦敦南部地区的需求，当时这里已经是世界上最大的城市，就像另一个更古老的板球场——也就是罗德板球场——迎合其北部地区的需求一样。这两个球场是体育的实体象征，
a new kind of entertainment, an industrial form of entertainment, because it is serving an industrial megalopolis. So London is sprawling, it's rich, it's teeming with inhabitants. And these inhabitants, lots of them now, are consumers who have both the time and the money to sit down and watch a man walk around a field, as well as a host of other occasions. So it reflects the development of leisure as much as anything else, and also suburbanism, right? Because these are effectively what would then have been called suburban grounds. Yes. And that's interesting because Kennington is now a suburb of London. It's being absorbed into the kind of the mass of the city. But previously it had been a common, which is a vast expanse of open public land.
一种新型的娱乐，一种工业化的娱乐，因为它服务于一个工业大都市。所以伦敦正在蔓延，它很富有，到处都是居民。而这些居民，其中许多现在都是消费者，他们既有时间和金钱坐下来看一个男人绕着场地走圈，也有时间和金钱参与许多其他活动。它在很大程度上反映了休闲的发展，还有郊区化，对吧？因为这些实际上就是当时被称为郊区球场的地方。是的。这很有趣，因为肯宁顿现在是伦敦的一个郊区。它已经被吞并到城市的大规模扩张中了。但在此之前，它曾是一个公地，是一片广阔的开阔公共土地。
That's why it's called a common. Because it was close to London. It had provided Londoners with the kind of place of public recreation. It's where you would go out to breathe fresh air. The recreation you could find there included sports of all kinds. And as London expands and the Common starts to vanish beneath brick, the Oval is founded to ensure that there would be at least some open ground where people could continue to play cricket or as we will see football as well. And in that sense, the Oval is not just looking forward to the future. It is a reminder of the role that Commons had played in providing recreation for people
这就是为什么它被称为公地。因为它靠近伦敦。它为伦敦人提供了一种公共娱乐场所。那是你出去呼吸新鲜你在那里可以找到的娱乐活动包括各种体育运动。随着伦敦的扩张和公地开始在砖墙下消失，椭圆球场应运而生，以确保至少还有一些开阔的土地供人们继续打板球，或者正如我们将看到的，也用来踢足球。从这个意义上说，椭圆球场不仅在展望未来。它还在提醒人们公地在为英国乃至其他国家的
in England and indeed other countries as well. And these are kind of forms of entertainment that reach back to the medieval past. So there may be some listeners who are sort of thinking, oh gosh, I wish they were doing the war of the Spanish succession or something because sport isn't really history. But of course, sport is history. It's part of the texture of life for millions of people
人们提供娱乐方面所发挥的作用。这些是追溯到中世纪过去的娱乐形式。所以可能有一些听众会想，哦天哪，我希望他们讲的是西班牙王位继承战争之类的事情，因为体育根本不是历史。但当然，体育就是历史。它是千百万人生活质感的一部分，
who were here before us. And this week we've got a guest coming on, haven't we, Robert Coles, who is going to be talking about boxing. And he's written a brilliant book, this sporting life. And he makes the point, doesn't he, that historians, perhaps because they're often quite nerdy people, they tend to neglect sport or to slightly condescend to it when they write about it. They don't treat it with the importance that it deserves as a kind of specimen of social history. You agree with him, don't you? Because
他们曾在我们之前生活在这里。本周我们要请来一位嘉宾，对吧，罗伯特·科尔斯，他将谈论拳击。他写了一本精彩的书，名叫《这段体育生活》。他指出，历史学家们，也许是因为他们通常是相当书呆子气的人，往往会忽视体育，或者在撰写时对它略带屈尊俯就。他们没有像对待一种社会历史样本那样给予它应有的重要性。你同意他的看法，对吧？因为
obviously you've written about sport in the Greek and Roman worlds, or chariot racing, I guess, in Constantinople. Yeah, I think that what people do in their leisure time is fascinating. And sport in the modern world is such a huge part of people's lives, but it's also a huge part of the global economy. I mean, it's absolutely become a way for not just individuals anymore, but entire states to project their prestige and their power. So I think the story of how that has emerged is really significant. And so in that spirit, why don't we try and place this great feat of Richard Manx at the Oval in its proper historical context? I'd love that. We can do that first by looking at the history of pedestrianism, this kind of mad-sounding sport, now pretty much
显然你写过关于希腊和罗马世界的体育的文章，或者君士坦丁堡的战车比赛，我想是这样的。是的，我认为人们在闲暇时间做的事非常迷人。现代世界的体育是人们生活中如此巨大的一部分，但它也是全球经济的巨大一部分。我的意思是，它绝对已经成为不仅是个人，而且是整个国家宣示其声望和权力的一种方式。所以我认为这段历史是如何演变的故事非常重要。因此，本着这种精神，为什么我们不试着把理查德·曼克斯在椭圆球场这一伟大壮举置于其适当的历史背景中呢？我很乐意。我们可以先来看看步行赛的历史，这个听起来疯狂的运动，现在几乎已经被
forgotten, but one that was a topic of obsessional interest in the first half of 19th century Britain, you know, it becomes a complete national obsession. And then by looking at the significance of the venue where he does this feat, this incredible achievement of walking a thousand miles in 500 consecutive half hours, so namely the oval, why was it built where it was, and how did it subsequently influence the development of professional sport as we would recognise it today? Sounds brilliant. And I think that answering these questions, I hope, will make the case for the Oval as perhaps one of, if not the most historically significant of all modern sports grounds,
遗忘，但在19世纪上半叶的英国，它曾是一个令人痴迷的话题，你知道的，它成了一种彻底的国家痴迷。然后通过审视他完成这一壮举的场馆的重要性——即在连续500个半小时内步行1,000英里的不可思议成就——也就是椭圆球场，为什么它会建在那个地方，以及它是如何随后影响我们今天所认识的职业体育的发展的？听起来太棒了。而且我认为回答这些问题，我希望，能够将椭圆球场证明为所有现代运动场中最具历史重要性的之一（如果不是最重要的话），
kind of the prototype for so much that follows. Okay, but Stephanie up there with the ground that invented European football, which is modern. So let us start with pedestrianism, though. So you compare it in your notes with boxing and cricket. So a sport that is basically born of the 18th. century obsession with gambling. Yes. So people are betting money on people walking around a track or down the street or whatever,
可以说是后续许多事物的原型。好吧，但至少它的地位与发明欧洲足球的那个球场不相上下，那是现代的。那么，让我们从步行赛开始吧。你在笔记中将它与拳击和板球进行了比较。所以这是一项基本上诞生于18世纪痴迷于赌博的运动。是的。所以人们把钱押在人们绕着跑道或沿街步行等等上面，
which seems mad, but we know that the Georgians love to bet. So that's actually pretty plausible. Yeah. And the thing is that it's something that appeals both to the upper classes, to the very highest echelons of society and to the vast mass of people. And actually, foot races, so not people running, but just walking, have been a first feature of kind of fairs and public celebrations since at least the restoration back in the 17th century. Oh, they knew how to have fun. They really did. The merry monarch. Nothing but
这看起来很疯狂，但我们知道乔治王朝时期的人们喜欢下注。所以这其实相当可信。是的。而且关键在于，它既吸引上流社会、社会最高阶层，也吸引广大普通民众。实际上，赛跑——不是跑步，仅仅是步行——至少从17世纪的王政复辟时期起，就一直是集市和公共庆祝活动的主要特色。哦，他们真懂得怎么玩乐。他们确实如此。快乐的君主。除了
fun. But noblemen were bet on these, right? Absolutely. So it's completely part of the climate of aristocratic gambling. So it's not just happening in fairs. It's happening in the kind of gentleman's clubs where you go to give talks about yourself. So in the 18th century, famously this saw kind of aristocrats in their clubs bet on all kinds of mad things so would a pigeon leave a window ledge within a given time
快乐别无他物。但贵族们会在这上面下注，对吧？绝对的。所以这完全是贵族赌博氛围的一部分。所以它不仅发生在集市上。它发生在那种你可以去发表关于你自己的演讲的绅士俱乐部里。所以在18世纪，这有一个著名的现象，贵族们在他们的俱乐部里对各种疯狂的事情下注，比如一只鸽子会在给定的时间内离开窗台吗，
or perhaps the most notorious one there's a bet that one of the gamblers would be able to have sex and I quote in a balloon 1,000 yards from the earth right so these are the kind of things oh dear I've just lost Shropshire that kind of thing because the pigeon has flown off or his lordship hasn't managed to get in the hot air balloon
或者也许是最臭名昭著的一个，有一个赌局是其中一个赌徒将能够——引述一下——“在离地1,000码的高空热气球里发生性关系”，对吧？所以这就是那种事情。哦亲爱的，我刚刚输掉了什罗普郡，诸如此类的事情。因为鸽子飞走了，或者他的勋爵大人没能和风骚女人一起坐上热气球。
with a strumpet all of that But they will use their servants, won't they? So basically footmen racing, is that right? They'll race their footmen? Yes. And again, this reaches back to the restoration. So Samuel Peeps, of course, I mean, he loves his pleasures. And so he's a big enthusiast for footman racing.
所有这些。但他们会使用他们的仆人，对吧？所以基本上是男仆赛跑，是这样的吗？他们会让他们的男仆赛跑？是的。同样，这可以追溯到王政复辟时期。所以塞缪尔·皮普斯，当然啦，我的意思是，他热爱他的快乐。所以他是男仆赛跑的超级狂热爱好者。
So on the 30th of July 1663, he reports how the town talk this day is of nothing but the great foot race run this day on banstered downs between Lee, the Duke of Richmond's footman and a tailor, a famous runner. And Lee has beat him, though the king and Duke of York and all. men almost did bet three or four to one upon the tailor's head. So the king, the Duke of York, I mean, it doesn't get higher than that. Wow. And so this is an enthusiasm that runs through the 17th century, through the 18th century, into the Napoleonic Wars. And in the fight against France, the fight against Napoleon, the craze for gambling on foot races starts to merge with something
所以在1663年7月30日，他报道说，这天全城谈论的除了这天在班斯特丘陵举行的伟大的男仆赛跑外别无他物，参赛者是里奇蒙公爵的男仆李和一位著名的赛跑裁缝。而李战胜了他，尽管国王、约克公爵以及几乎所有人都在裁缝身上下了三比一或四比一的赌注。所以国王、约克公爵，我的意思是，地位不能再高了。哇。所以这是一种贯穿17世纪、18世纪并延续到拿破仑战争的热情。在与法国的战斗中、在与拿破仑的战斗中，对赛跑下注的狂热开始与我们经常联系起来讨论的另一件事融合在一起，
else that we've talked about a lot in connection, say, with Nelson. And this is a relish for displays of heroic manliness. Right. And people believe that you can prove your manliness by walking. Is that right? Yes, they do. They do. And when you contemplate the feats that are achieved, I mean, you'd see why. So the guy who blazes the path for this emerging sport of pedestrianism in the first decade
比如纳尔逊。这就是对英雄般男子气概展现的热衷。对。人们相信你可以通过步行来证明你的男子气概。是这样吗？是的，他们会的。他们确实如此。当你沉思所取得的壮举时，我的意思是，你会明白为什么。所以在19世纪的前十年，为这个新兴的步行运动开辟道路的人
of the 19th century is a Scotsman called Robert Barclay Oladice. And he's universally known as Captain Barclay. And he comes from a very old and distinguished Scottish family. He's a descendant, I think, of a cousin of the founder of Barclay's bank. He's a military man, so hence Captain Barclay. He's served with the Royal Welsh Fusiliers, and he is an archetypal sportsman. So when he's not off serving with His Majesty's army, he is training and supporting boxers and himself engaging in boxing.
是一个名叫罗伯特·巴克利·奥拉迪斯的苏格兰人。他普遍被称为巴克利船长。他来自一个非常古老且杰出的苏格兰家族。我想他是巴克利银行创始人的表亲的后代。他是个军人，因此被称为巴克利船长。他在皇家威尔士燧发枪团服役，他是典型的运动员。所以当他不在国王的军队服役时，他就在训练、支持拳击手并亲自参与拳击。
But his main claim to fame is his stunning feats of what come to be called pedestrianism. And he seems to kind of have worked up to this. by every so often doing some kind of mad feet. So in 1801, it's a very, very muddy day. Right. And he thinks, oh, mud, brilliant. There's a challenge. And so he walks 110 miles in under 19 and a half hours
但他成名的主要原因是他那些后来被称为步行赛的惊人壮举。他似乎是通过不时进行某种疯狂的壮举来为之蓄力的。所以在1801年，那是一个非常非常泥泞的日子。对。他想，哦，泥浆，太棒了。这真是个挑战。于是他在这些泥泞的小路上步行了110英里，耗时不到19个半小时，
along these muddy lanes just to show that he can do it. I'm going to go on record. I don't believe you could guarantee that all 110 miles would be muddy. I think you could talk up the mud, but I believe that parts of that track would be just less muddy. Okay, that's the bracing skepticism for which you are renowned. 1805, I don't know whether you're going to be skeptical about this. He has his breakfast and then he thinks, I'll go for a walk.
只是为了证明他能做到。我要正式声明一下。我不相信你能保证全部110英里都是泥泞的。我认为你可以夸大泥泞的程度，但我相信赛道的某些部分肯定没那么泥泞。好吧，这就是你闻名遐迩的令人振奋的怀疑精神。1805年，我不知道你对这个会不会持怀疑态度。他吃完早饭，然后想，我去散个步。
He walks 72 miles and then he sits down for dinner. No, I believe that because I'm doing something similar because I'm walking around the Welsh coast, as you know, with my mates, James and Tim from school. And how far have you got with that? A lot of miles. A lot of miles. We started in the top North Wales, which is quite grim, if I'm completely honest. In about 2040, we'll be in the nice bit with all the beaches and stuff. But we're doing absolutely Herculean feeds.
他走了72 miles，然后坐下来吃晚饭。不，我相信这个，因为我也在做类似的事情，因为正如你所知，我正和我的学校伙伴詹姆斯和蒂姆一起沿着威尔士海岸步行。你在这上面进展到哪一步了？走了很多英里。很多英里。我们从北威尔士的最顶端开始，说实话，那里相当阴暗。大约在2040年，我们就会到达那些有着各种海滩的好地方。但我们正在做绝对海格力斯般的壮举。
People are very welcome to come and watch. I'd love that, actually. I mean, maybe you could sell the rights to some sporting channel. Why have Golhanger not snap this up? Mad. Yeah. So you and Captain Barclay both, absolute heroes of pedestrianism. And it's in 1809 that Captain Barclay really puts his name on the map.
非常欢迎大家来看。其实我很乐意。我的意思是，也许你可以把版权卖给某个体育频道。为什么高杭公司没有抢购这个？太疯狂了。所以你和巴克利船长都是步行赛的绝对英雄。正是1809年，巴克利船长真正让他的名字名扬四方。
So this is a feat that rings down the ages. And the Times cover gives a full report to it. And it happened on the 12th of July 1809. The Times report runs two days later on the 14th of July, and it comes from a circuit at Newmarket. So here is the Times. The gentleman on Wednesday completed his arduous pedestrian undertaking to walk a thousand miles in a thousand successive hours
所以这是一个流传后世的壮举。《泰晤士报》的报道对此进行了全面报道。它发生在1809年7月12日。《泰晤士报》的报道在两天后的7月14日刊出，消息来自纽马克的赛马场。以下是《泰晤士报》的内容：这位绅士于星期三完成了他艰巨的步行任务，在1,000个连续的小时内步行1,000英里，
at the rate of a mile in each and every hour. He had until 4 o'clock p.m. to finish his task, but he performed his last mile in the quarter of an hour after three with perfect ease and great spirit amidst an end. immense concourse of spectators. So pluck and spectators, everything that you'd want in a sporting occasion. Let me just work this out. He started this on the 1st of June and he finished it on the 12th of July. So for 42 days, he walked every hour of every day. Surely even the most obtuse listener will have spotted some potential drawbacks.
速率是每小时恰好一英里。他直到下午4点才完成任务，但在大量观众的簇拥下，他在3点15分从容不迫、精神饱满地完成了最后一英里。所以有毅力，有观众，具备了一场体育盛会想要的一切。让我来算算。他从6月1日开始，到7月12日结束。所以在42天里，他每天的每一个小时都在走路。Surely即使是最愚钝的听众也会发现一些潜在的缺点。
When does he eat? When does he sleep? When does he go to the toilet? How does that work? So what he does is he walks back to back miles. So he will walk a mile at the end of one hour and then carry on into the next hour, which then kind of freeze up time. So he has kind of 90 minute intervals where he could go to the toilet or snatch a few minutes sleep. So he walks in every hour, but he doesn't walk for the whole hour, basically.
他什么时候吃东西？他什么时候睡觉？他什么时候上厕所？那是怎么运作的？所以他做的是背靠背地走英里。所以他会在一个小时结束时走一英里，然后继续进入下一个小时，这样就空出了时间。所以他大约有90分钟的间隔时间可以去上厕所或抓紧时间睡几分钟。所以他每个小时都走，但他并不是走整个小时，基本上是这样。
No, so he has to walk a mile every hour. Right. And then once he's done it, then he can have a rest. The sleep is a big issue. I think. He has kind of 90-minute bursts where he can have sleep and then he gets woken up. For 42 days, that's bonkers. Yeah, I mean, it's tough. And this is why it's so celebrated and it features on, you know, in all the newspapers, alongside kind of news of British victories and the Peninsula War and so on. And in fact, the maddest thing of all is that five days after he's completed this walk, Captain Barclay is sailing with his regiment for the low countries. And it goes disastrously wrong. but Captain Barclay continues to be hailed
不，所以他必须每小时走一英里。然后一旦他完成了，他就可以休息。睡眠是个大问题。我想。他有大约90分钟的碎片时间可以睡觉，然后他会被叫醒。持续42天，这太疯狂了。是的，我的意思是，这很艰难。这就是为什么它如此受到庆祝，并出现在所有报纸上，与英国在半岛战争中的胜利等新闻并列。事实上，最疯狂的事情是，在完成这次步行五天后，巴克利船长带着他的低地国家联队起航了。结果糟透了，但巴克利船长继续被誉为
as a kind of absolute model of British manhood and proof that even though the British Army may not be able to defeat the French in the sporting fields of the low countries We could outwalk them We can absolutely outwalk them because this is not something the French are getting up to No, of course not.
英国男子气概的绝对典范，并证明了尽管英国军队可能无法在低地国家的体育场上击败法国人，但我们可以走过他们。我们绝对可以走过他们，因为这不是法国人会去干的事。当然不是。
So a great cause of patriotic pride. But also Captain Barclay, you're presenting him as this sort of selfless incarnation of British manhood, but am I not right in saying he's making a lot of money from this. I don't think that that diminishes his pluck and manhood. Okay.
所以这是一个巨大的爱国骄傲的来源。但巴克利船长，你把他表现为英国男子气概这种大公无私的化身，但我没说错的话，他从中赚了很多钱吧。我不认为这会减损他的毅力和男子气概。好吧。
But yes, he's very, very well remunerated. And again, the Times covers this. It's fascinating. It's also a way in which it seems so modern that the sporting feats are celebrated, but there is an obsessive interest in how much money is being generated. So the Times puts it, Captain Barkley had a large sum depending upon his undertaking. The aggregate of the bets is supposed to amount to £100,000. I mean, that's a lot of money at the time.
但是的，他报酬非常非常丰厚。同样，《泰晤士报》也对此进行了报道。这太迷人了。这也是一种看起来很现代的方式，体育壮举受到庆祝，但人们对产生了多少钱有着痴迷的兴趣。正如《泰晤士报》所说：巴克利船长有一大笔赌注压在他的任务上。赌注总额据信达到了100,000英镑。我的意思是，在当时这是一大笔钱。
And so it's not surprising that in the years that follow Barclay's great feat, there are lots of pedestriansists who attempt not just to emulate it, but to surpass it. So in 1815, you have an Essex man named Josiah Eaton who goes just that little bit better than Barclay by undertaking a walk of 1,100 miles in 1,100 hours. And he does this going round and round Blackheath, which is a common in south-east London. and he completes that on Boxing Day and it must have been scheduled because they would have worked out when he would finish it and this again is a pointer
因此，毫不奇怪的是，在巴克利这一伟大壮举之后的几年里，有许多步行者不仅试图效仿它，还试图超越它。所以在1815年，有一个名叫若西亚·伊顿的埃塞克斯人，他通过承担在1,100小时内步行1,100英里的任务，比巴克利做得稍好了一点。他绕着布莱克希思一圈又一圈地走，布莱克希思是伦敦东南部的一个公地。他在节礼日完成了这一壮举，这肯定是计划好的，因为他们会计算出他会在什么时候完成，这再次指向了
to the great British tradition of sport on Boxing Day. Yeah, of course, yeah. And indeed in Australia, so football and cricket. Yeah, and then the sport goes from strength to strength, doesn't it?
英国在节礼日进行体育运动的伟大传统。是的，当然，是的。确实在澳大利亚，足球和板球也是如此。然后这项运动蓬勃发展，不是吗？
So by the late 1830s, you're really into a golden age of pedestrianism. 1838th, golden year of pedestrian feats. So that year you have one pedestrian who walks 1,250 miles in successive 1,000 hours. So that's basically one and a quarter miles every hour. A bit like cricket, there's quite a lot of maths involved in pedestrianism.
所以在18世纪30年代末，你真正进入了步行赛的黄金时代。1838年，步行壮举的黄金年。那年有一位步行者在连续1,000小时内走了1,250英里。所以这基本上是每小时走一英里又四分之一。有点像板球，步行赛中涉及相当多的数学。
Then another succeeds in walking 1,500 miles in 1,000 hours. And then later in the year, he completes 1,750 miles in 1,000 hours. So in other words, you're having less and less time to complete your miles. But it is Richard Manx in 1851, this extraordinary feat, who passes the ultimate test. So, Dominic, who is Richard Manx, this great forgotten British sportsman? So people know that actually
然后另一个人成功在1,000小时内走了1,500英里。接着在今年晚些时候，他完成了在1,000小时内走1,750英里。换句话说，你完成英里的时间越来越少。但在1851年，理查德·曼克斯以其非凡的壮举，通过了终极考验。那么，多米尼克，理查德·曼克斯是谁，这位被遗忘的伟大英国运动员？所以人们知道实际上
there are two great sporting heroes in British history. One is Steve Bull and Wolverhampton Wanderers who was from the West Midlands. And Richard Manx, is no coincidence. He's also from the West Midlands. He's a bricklayer, isn't he, from Solihull?
英国历史上有两位伟大的体育英雄。一位是史蒂夫·布尔和狼队，他来自西米德兰兹郡。而理查德·曼克斯，绝非巧合。他也来自西米德兰兹郡。他是一名砌砖工，对吧，来自索利哈尔？
And the bricklaying is key to this, isn't it? Yeah. People say that basically he's used to toiling for hours and hours. Yeah. And Bricklaying has given him tremendous endurance, stamina and strength. Yes. And before he takes up pedestrianism, he's been a runner, a middle distance runner, then a
而砌砖是其中的关键，对吧？是的。人们说他基本上习惯了数小时又数小时的辛劳。是的。砌砖赋予了他极大的耐力、体力和力量。是的。在他开始步行赛之前，他曾是一名跑步运动员，中长跑运动员，然后是
long distance runner. And he ends up with a splendid nickname of the Warwickshire Antelope, which is actually I don't know if I've ever mentioned this, Dominic before, but my great uncle, Charles Holland, I was an Olympic cyclist and was known as the Midlands Rocket. So another Midlands athlete. Yeah. I think this is about the 40th time on the podcast, but it's lovely to have him back. Well, we've got Steve Bull, my great uncle, and Richard Manx.
长跑运动员。他最终得到了一个响亮的外号——沃里克郡羚羊，其实我不知道我以前有没有提过这个，多米尼克，但我的曾叔父查尔斯·霍兰德曾是一名奥运会自行车手，被称为米德兰兹火箭。所以又是一位米德兰兹运动员。是的。我想这是我在播客里第40次提到了，但很高兴能再次请他出场。好吧，我们有史蒂夫·布尔、我的曾叔父和理查德·曼克斯。
And so Richard Manx enters the history books of pedestrianism in 1851. This is his Anas Maribelis. So in June that year, he goes to a cricket club in Sheffield. And I will quote Derek Martin, who's written a great book on this, a short history of the Barclay match. So the Barclay match is, you know, the thing that he established. And again, apologies, there's quite a lot of maths here. So this is what he does in Sheffield. He'd walk 1,000 quarter miles in 1,000 consecutive quarter hours, i.e. 250 miles in 10 days and 10 hours.
于是理查德·曼克斯在1851年进入了步行赛的历史书。这是他的绝代盛年。所以在同年的6月，他去了谢菲尔德的一个板球俱乐部。我将引用德里克·马丁的一段话，他写了一本关于这方面的伟大书籍，《巴克利比赛简史》。所以巴克利比赛就是，你知道的，他建立的那项赛事。再次抱歉，这里有相当多的数学。所以这就是他在谢菲尔德做的事。他要在1,000个连续的刻钟内步行1,000个四分之一英里，即在10天10小时内步行250英里。
Then immediately 1,000 half miles in 1,000 consecutive half hours, i.e. 500 miles in 20 days and 20 hours, Dominic's face, followed immediately by a conventional Barclay match, i.e. that is the 1,000 miles in 1,000 consecutive hours. And this would amount in all to the monumental total of 1,750 miles in 72 days and 22. hours. And as if this were not enough, he would begin walking his quarter miles at the beginning of each quarter hour, the half miles on the half hour and the miles on the hour. So in other words, he is going beyond what Barclay had done. He's not giving himself time to have, you know, lengthy sleeps or anything. When he's doing the quarter miles, I mean, you know, he's having to snap five minute, ten minute snatches of sleep. So really tough. I have to say the reporting of this reminds me of baseball or indeed cricket Tom, as in it's obsessed with stats and it sucks all the
然后立即在1,000个连续的半小时内步行1,000个半英里，即在20天20小时内步行500英里——多米尼克的表情——紧接着是一场传统的巴克利比赛，即在1,000个连续小时内步行1,000英里。这一切加起来将是一个惊人的总数：在72天22小时内步行1,750英里。如果这还不够，他将在每个刻钟开始时开始走四分之一英里，在半点时走半英里，在整点时走英里。换句话说，他超越了巴克利所做的事。他没有给自己留出时间去睡长觉之类的。当他在走四分之一英里时，我的意思是，你知道的，他不得不抓紧五分钟、十分钟的碎片时间睡觉。所以真的非常艰难。我不得不说，对这件事的报道让我想到了棒球或板球，汤姆，因为它痴迷于数据，并且吸干了这项惊险刺激的运动的所有乐趣。
joy out of this swashbuckling sport. Well, obviously, opinions on that will differ. But this is why he's building up to the ultimate challenge, which is what he does at the Oval. He has to walk a thousand miles in a thousand half hours, i.e. has to walk a thousand miles in 500 hours. Right. So that's unbelievably demanding.
好吧，很显然，对此的意见会有所不同。但这就是为什么他在为终极挑战做准备，也就是他在椭圆球场做的事。他必须在1,000个半小时内步行1,000英里，即必须在500小时内步行1,000英里。对。所以这要求高得令人难以置信。
A thousand miles in 500 hours. I mean, actually, when you think about it, walking a thousand miles is bonkers. I mean, any time, but to do it in 500 hours. Yeah. And this is a massive sporting deal, right? this is a massive public occasion. People in London are obsessed with this, are genuinely obsessed with it.
500小时内步行1,000英里。我的意思是，实际上仔细想想，步行1,000英里太疯狂了。我的意思是，任何时候，但在500小时内完成。是的。这是一件巨大的体育大事，对吧？这是一件巨大的公众盛会。伦敦的人们对此痴迷，是真的痴迷。
I think it is seen as being the Everest of pedestrianism. Once it's been scaled, no one will ever be able to kind of rival it. And people must have been really looking forward to it. Like, Will Messi ever win the World Cup? It's that kind of thing, right? Will Manx pull off this amazing feat. Yes, the sense of occasion is absolutely massive.
我认为这被视为步行赛的珠穆朗玛峰。一旦它被征服，将再也没有人能够与之匹敌。人们一定非常期待它。就像梅西会赢得世界杯吗？就是那种感觉，对吧？曼克斯会完成这个惊人的壮举吗？是的，那种盛会的感觉绝对是巨大的。
And as with any kind of great sporting event, the details are kind of lovingly preserved and cherished and become part of sporting folklore. So things like, you know, what is he eating while he's doing this? So the London Illustrated News reports, he ate around 10 times each day, a diet of game and poultry. Roast beef, mutton and chops, washed down with strong beef tea. Old ale was his favourite restorative, while through the night he drank tea fortified with brandy. Then there are kind of occasional moments where he seems to wobble, perhaps on the verge of giving up. So the 28th October, it rains all day, and it's reported that this gets him down.
而且就像任何伟大的体育赛事一样，细节被满怀爱意地保存和珍视，并成为体育民间传说的一部分。比如，他在做这件事时吃什么？所以《伦敦画报》报道：他每天大约吃10次，饮食包括野味和家禽。烤牛肉、羊肉和排骨，配上浓牛肉茶。陈年爱尔啤酒是他最喜欢的恢复体力的饮品，而整夜他则喝加了白兰地的茶。然后有一些偶尔的时刻，他似乎动摇了，也许到了放弃的边缘。所以10月28日，整天下雨，据报道这让他很沮丧。
The following day, somebody goes to wake him up after he's snatched, you know, five minutes sleep, and he wakes up and punches the guy in the face. He's so angry and upset. And then on the final day of the walk, it's reported at half past two o'clock on Friday morning, so dead of night. He refused to rise, cried like a child, and said to the timekeeper, I shall walk no more, asking, do you want to kill me? But at length, he was induced to persevere unto the finish.
第二天，有人去叫醒他，此前他抓紧时间睡了（你知道的）五分钟，他醒来后一拳打在那个家伙的脸上。他太生气、太沮丧了。然后在步行的最后一天，据报道在星期五凌晨两点半，也就是深夜。他拒绝起床，像个孩子一样哭泣，对计时员说：“我再也不走了”，并问道：“你们想杀死我吗？”但最终，他还是被劝说坚持到了终点。
That's mad that on the last day, he thought of dropping out. He's obviously a broken man by that point. I mean, that's it. That's why it's such a great sport, Dominic. You know, will he do it? Will he manage it? Will he get up? Will he punch someone in the face?
太疯狂了，在最后一天，他竟然想退赛。到那个时候他显然已经是一个心力交瘁的人了。我的意思是，就是这样。这就是为什么这是一项如此伟大的运动，多米尼克。你知道的，他会成功吗？他能做到吗？他能起来吗？他会打别人的脸吗？
He's been doing it for 999 miles and then on the thousand. He says, actually, I've had enough. I wish I never started. But that's precisely the tension. And you know, the madnessing of all. Go on. And this is noted by Dominic Hutton. Manx completes his 1,000th mile.
他已经走了999英里，然后在第一千英里时。他说，实际上，我受够了。我真希望我从未开始。但恰恰是这种张力。你知道的，最疯狂的是。说下去。多米尼克·阿顿注意到了这一点。曼克斯完成了他的第一千英里。
You know, it's been measured out around the outfield of the Oval. And then it gets properly measured. And they discover that he'd actually walk 12 miles further than he'd needed to. Oh, my word. Imagine you'd be gutted, wouldn't you? I mean, thank God it wasn't 12 miles less. Yeah, that would have been terrible. That would have been terrible.
你知道的，这是围绕着椭圆球场的 outfield 测量出来的。然后它得到了正确的测量。他们发现他实际上比需要的路程多走了12英里。哦，天哪。想象一下你会感到极度沮丧，对吧？我的意思是，谢天谢地，不是少走了12英里。是的，那太可怕了。那会非常糟糕。
So a huge success for Richard Manx. But it's also a great success for the ground that staged it, the Oval. Okay. Because it's generated massive media and public interest. It's generated massive crowds. And above all, and the most important thing from the perspective of the consortium that owns the ground, it's generated massive amounts of cash. Right.
所以对于理查德·曼克斯来说是一场巨大的成功。但对于主办它的场馆——椭圆球场——来说，也是一场巨大的成功。好吧。因为它产生了巨大的媒体和公众关注。它产生了巨大的观众群体。最重要的是，从拥有该场馆的财团的角度来看，它产生了巨额的现金。对。
And his feat of pedestrianism is drawing on traditions of spectacle and gambling that reach back hundreds of years on Kennington Common. But of course, as we've said, it's also looking forward to this new era of stats and professionalism and the monetisation of what is increasingly coming to be thought of as organised sport. And Dominic, you've heard me say it before. You're about to hear me say it again. I think there is no stadium in the world that better illustrates how we went from kind of pre-modern entertainments to modern sport than the Oval. And that's why in the second half, I hope you will allow me. to stress test that proposition.
他的步行壮举汲取了在肯宁顿公地上延续了数百年的奇观和赌博传统。当然，正如我们所说，它也在展望数据、专业化以及日益被视为有组织的体育的商业化这一新时代。多米尼克，你听我以前说过。你即将再次听到我说。我认为世界上没有哪个体育场比椭圆球场更能说明我们是如何从前现代娱乐走向现代体育的。这就是为什么在下半场，我希望你能允许我。压力测试这一命题。
Okay, so join us after the break when Tom considers one of the most intriguing questions in all history. This episode is brought to you by The Long Walk, which is out in cinemas on the 12th of September. This is an adaptation of Stephen King's very first book. He wrote it in 1967 when the Vietnam War was tearing America apart and thousands of American boys were being conscripted to fight in their war
好的，那么休息过后请继续收听，届时汤姆将探讨历史中一个最迷人的问题。本剧集由将于9月12日上映的电影《长途步行》赞助播出。这是斯蒂芬·金第一部小说的改编版。他在1967年越南战争撕裂美国、成千上万的美国男孩被征召去打仗时写下了这本书，
and he published it in 1979. And the premise is brutally simple. You have 50 boys and basically you just have to keep walking and if you stop, then you get shot. And the whole reason for doing it is that at the end, if you are the one boy who survives, then you get untold riches. But of course, to get these riches, you have to outwalk the other 49. So it's directed by Francis Lawrence, who is behind several films in the Hunger Games series. And it stars the BAFTA rising star David Johnson. It stars Cooper Hoffman and, of course, my favourite actor, Mark Hamill, who supports Wolfampton Wanderers.
并在1979年出版。其前提残酷地简单。有50个男孩，基本上你只需不停地走，如果你停下来，你就会被中枪。这样做的全部原因在于，最后如果你是唯一一个幸存的男孩，你将获得数不尽的财富。但当然，要得到这些财富，你必须比其他49个男孩走得更远。该片由曾执导《饥饿游戏》系列多部电影的弗朗西斯·劳伦斯执导。主演有英国电影学院奖新星大卫·约翰逊。主演还有库珀·霍夫曼，当然还有我最喜欢的演员、狼队球迷马克·哈米尔。
So you can watch The Long Walk exclusively in cinemas from the 12th of September, and you can book tickets at the longwalkmovie.com.com.com.ukukukuk. Hello, I'm William Durimple. And I'm Anita Arndon. We're the hosts of another Goalhanger show, Empire. And we are here to tell you about a recent series we've done on partition. On the 14th and 15th of August, 1947, Pakistan and India announced their independence from the British Empire. But as these nations gained their freedom, their rushed and violent division resulted in the deaths of well over a million people and the forced migration
因此，您可以在9月12日起独家在电影院观看《长途步行》，您可以在 thelongwalkmovie.com 预订电影票。你好，我是威廉·达林普尔。我是阿尼塔·阿南德。我们是高杭节目《帝国》的主持人。我们在这里向大家介绍我们最近做的一个关于印巴分治的系列节目。在1947年8月14日和15日，巴基斯坦和印度宣布脱离大英帝国独立。但随着这些国家获得自由，他们仓促而暴力的分裂导致了远超一百万人的死亡以及被迫迁移
of over 14 million more. It's a piece of South Asian history that many people are familiar with. But in this series, we want to explore it alongside four less well-known partitions, which continue to affect the region in monumental ways. Yeah, you're quite right. In one episode, we dissect how Dubai almost became part of modern India. And in another, we're going to unpack the history behind the headlines about the conflict in Kashmir. We also explore how the separation of Burma from India is linked to the origin of the Rohingya genocide and how East and West Pakistan separated in 1971 to create Bangladesh.
再增加1400多万。这是许多人都很熟悉的一段南亚历史。但在本系列中，我们希望探讨它，并结合另外四个鲜为人知的印巴分治事件，这些事件继续以巨大的方式影响着该地区。是的，你说得对。在一集中，我们剖析了迪拜差点如何成为现代印度的一部分。在另一集中，我们将剖析关于克什米尔冲突的头条新闻背后的历史。我们还探讨了缅甸从印度的分离如何与罗兴亚种族灭绝的起源联系在一起，以及东西巴基斯坦如何在1971年分离以创建孟加拉国。
So if you'd like to hear more about the five-party genocide, that completely transformed modern Asia and how the weight of the memory of partition has been passed down through the generations. We've left a clip of the series at the end of this episode for you to listen to. An affectionate remembrance of English cricket, which died at the Oval on the 29th of August 1882,
因此，如果您想了解更多关于彻底改变了现代亚洲的五方种族灭绝，以及分治记忆的重量是如何代代相传的。我们在本集结尾为您留下了该系列的片段以供收听。对英格兰板球运动的深情追思，该运动于1882年8月29日在椭圆球场逝世，
deeply lamented by a large, circle of sorrowing friends and acquaintances, R.I.P. N.B. The body will be cremated and the ashes taken to Australia. So Tom, that's the most famous obituary in sporting history and it was published in the Sporting Times on the 2nd of September 1882. And I know you're a big cricket fan. There are none bigger. So would you like to explain to our more skeptical listeners American listeners, what on earth is going on? So it commemorates a humiliating defeat of the England national cricket team by the Australian national cricket team four days earlier at the Oval.
深切哀悼者包括一大群悲伤的朋友和熟人，安息吧。注意：遗体将被火化，骨灰将被运往澳大利亚。所以汤姆，这是板球史上最著名的讣告，它于1882年9月2日发表在《体育时报》上。我知道你是个板球大球迷。没有比这更大的了。那么你想向我们更持怀疑态度的听众美国听众解释一下到底是怎么回事吗？所以它是为了纪念四天前在椭圆球场英格兰国家板球队被澳大利亚国家板球队羞辱性的击败。
And it's that phrase, the ashes will be taken to Australia that will have an enduring afterlife. Because the following winter, the England national cricket team go to Australia and the captain vows before he leaves England that he's going to recover those ashes. and the notion that England and Australia, whenever they play each other at cricket, are competing for the ashes, very rapidly catches on. And today the ashes remain probably the most celebrated, the most enduring international rivalry in cricket, if actually not all sports.
正是那句“骨灰将被运往澳大利亚”这句话将产生持久的后世影响。因为随后的冬天，英格兰板球队前往澳大利亚，队长在离开英格兰之前发誓要找回那些骨灰。英格兰和澳大利亚每当在板球比赛中相遇时，都在争夺骨灰的观念，很快就流行开来。今天，骨灰仍然可能是板球界甚至所有体育界最著名、最持久的国际对决。
So the ashes will be competed for later this year in Australia. And it all begins at the Oval, which is hardly surprising because, of course, the Oval was founded as a cricket ground, and it remains one to this day. but your skepticism would be justified if I was merely talking about cricket, but I'm not, because the impact the Oval has on the evolution of professional sport is not confined to cricket. So we've seen the role that it played in pedestrianism in the career of Richard Manx, the Warwickshire Antelope. But of course, pedestrianism fades away, perhaps because once Richard Manx has completed that feat, there's nowhere for the sport to go. But the Oval provides a stage,
因此，骨灰将于今年晚些时候在澳大利亚争夺。这一切都始于椭圆球场，这并不奇怪，因为椭圆球场当然是作为板球场建立的，至今仍是一个板球场。但如果我只是在谈论板球，你的怀疑是合理的，但我不是，因为椭圆球场对职业体育演变的影响并不局限于板球。所以我们看到了它在理查德·曼克斯（沃里克郡羚羊）的职业生涯中在步行竞走运动中所发挥的作用。但当然，步行竞走运动逐渐消失了，也许是因为一旦理查德·曼克斯完成了这一壮举，这项运动就无处可去了。但椭圆球场提供了一个舞台，
not just for cricket, but also for two sports that in the second half of the 19th century are exploding in popularity and are destined to have a much brighter future than pedestrianism. And Dominic, the first of these is a sport that you are particularly fond of. Yeah, it's football, association football. So obviously people have been playing football, various kinds of football for a long time, but there's a great vogue, isn't there, in the middle of the 19th century, for codifying games. And this is really borne out of another subject we've done on the rest of this history,
不仅是为了板球，还为了两项运动，这两项运动在19世纪下半叶人气暴涨，注定比步行竞走运动有更光明的未来。多米尼克，第一项是您特别喜欢的运动。是的，是足球，协会足球。所以很明显，人们踢足球，各种各样的足球已经有很长时间了，但在19世纪中期，有一股巨大的风潮，不是吗，就是将比赛规范化。这实际上源于我们在“历史的其余部分”中做过的另一个主题，
was public schools, boarding schools. So in 1863, a group of, I think they're largely ex-public schoolboys had gathered to codify the rules of association football, as it was called. So that's why Americans call it soccer. Basically, so that people who'd been to different schools and had learned slightly different rules of the game could have a nationally standardized version of the game. And then, of course, it really takes off. And then the other game, Rugby Union. So famously emerges at Rugby School, hence the name. And the thing there was that the boys who played football there since the 1830s have been picking up the ball, which is obviously in association football you're not allowed to do unless you're the goalkeeper. And the backstory
是公立学校，寄宿学校。所以在1863年，一群，我认为他们主要是前公立学校男生聚集在一起，规范协会足球的规则，正如它被称为的那样。这就是为什么美国人称之为英式足球。基本上，以便去过不同学校并学习了略有不同比赛规则的人可以拥有全国统一版本的比赛。然后，当然，它真正腾飞了。然后是另一场比赛，橄榄球联盟。众所周知，它起源于橄榄球学校，因此得名。这里的情况是，自1830年代以来在那里踢足球的男孩们一直在捡球，这在协会足球中显然是不允许的，除非你是守门员。而背景故事
here is that picking up the ball had been outlawed in those football association rules. So some of the clubs had broken away. And the schism between the two codes, association football and rugby football, was formalised in 1871 by the foundation of the RFU, the rugby football union. So basically, now you have what was originally one sport turning into two, and of course rugby will then divide even further. And so for the Oval's point of view, I guess this is wonderful because they have codified sports that actually not just rich and well-connected boarding school boys, but also vast crowds of working men, are very enthusiastic about, which means a lot of opportunities for charging ticket prices. Yes, and for staging not just kind of local sporting events, but
在这里，捡起球在那些足球协会规则中已经被取缔了。所以一些俱乐部脱离了出去。这两种规则（协会足球和橄榄球）之间的分裂在1871年通过橄榄球联盟（RFU）的成立而正式化。所以基本上，现在你最初的一项运动变成了两项，当然橄榄球随后会分裂得更远。因此，从椭圆球场来看，我想这太棒了，因为他们有规范的运动，实际上不仅是富裕且人脉广大的寄宿学校男孩，而且广大工人阶层的群众也非常热衷于此，这意味着有很多收取票价的机会。是的，不仅是举办那种地方体育赛事，而且还
international ones. And the mad thing is that England against Australia at cricket is not the first international sports fixture to be staged at the Oval. Because in fact, by 1880, which is when the first cricket international test matches, as they're called, to be played in England is staged at the Oval. The ground has already hosted internationals in both football and rugby. It has also hosted athletics meetings. And even in 1889, it goes on to host a baseball match between the Chicago white stockings and an all-American team. And this is big, big news in London. Loads of celebrities come to watch it.
国际的。疯狂的是，英格兰对阵澳大利亚的板球比赛并不是在椭圆球场举办的第一场国际体育赛事。事实上，到了1880年，也就是在英格兰举行的第一场板球国际测试赛（所谓的测试赛）在椭圆球场举行时。该场地已经主办了足球和橄榄球的国际比赛。它还主办了田径会议。甚至在1889年，它还继续主办了一场芝加哥白袜队与全美明星队的棒球比赛。这在伦敦是特大新闻。许多名人来看它。
The Prince of Wales turns up. W.G. Grace, who's this huge kind of barrel-chested, hearsuit cricketer, one of the most famous men in late Victorian England. They all go, but inevitably, this being England, it gets rained off. Of course it does. And sadly, baseball doesn't really take off as a result. So, of course, the Oval is a cricket ground, but it's absolutely not just. just a cricket ground. And in the mid-19th century, this lack of specialisation is reflecting
威尔士亲王出现了。W·G·格雷斯，这个块头巨大、满脸胡须的板球运动员，是维多利亚时代晚期英国最著名的人物之一。他们都去了，但不可避免地，作为英国，它下雨取消了。当然会这样。可悲的是，棒球并没有因此真正流行起来。所以，当然，椭圆球场是一个板球场，但绝对不仅仅是。只是一个板球场。在19世纪中期，这种缺乏专业化反映了
kind of two influences. And one is its roots in the pre-industrial culture of Kennington Common, which plays host to every kind of conceivable sport. But it's also a reflection of the fact that its owners want to make as much money as possible. And that, of course, is looking forward to today's culture of hyper-professional sport. So let's start by looking backwards. So you said the pre-industrial culture of Kennington Common. So Kennington, the King's Estate, basically, the King's Farm or whatever. So it had belonged to the Crown. We know that Edward III gave it to Fend of the Restist's history, the Black Prince
两种影响。一是它根源于肯宁顿公地的更工业化之前的文化，这里是各种可想象的运动的举办地。但这也反映了一个事实，即它的所有者希望赚尽可能多的钱。当然，这展望了当今超级专业体育的文化。让我们首先回顾过去。所以你提到了肯宁顿公地的工业化前文化。所以肯宁顿，基本上是国王的地产，国王的农场或别的什么。所以它属于王室。我们知道爱德华三世把它送给了《历史的其余部分》的朋友，黑太子
in the 14th century. And from that point onwards, it had traditionally belonged to the heir to the throne, the Prince of Wales. Yes. So it has a kind of very strong royal connection. But it's also sediment the people's open space. So it's a common, an area where tenants of various manners, including the Prince of Wales, is that Kennington have a right to pasture their animals.
在14世纪。从那时起，它传统上属于王位继承人，威尔士亲王。是的。所以它有一种非常强烈的皇室联系。但它也是人民开放空间的沉淀。所以它是一个公地，肯宁顿的各种庄园的租户（包括威尔士亲王）有权在那里放牧他们的动物。
And anyone familiar with London, particularly South London, will know that it's covered with commons. So Clapham Commons, Streatham Common, Wimbledon Common, and so on. But the thing about Kennington is that of all the commons, it's the closest to the city of London and to Westminster. and over the course of the 17th and then into the 18th century, the city of London and Westminster are kind of congealing and cojoining to become one vast urban sprawl. And as a result of that, by the 18th century, Kennington Common is becoming the place where people from Westminster
任何熟悉伦敦，特别是南伦敦的人都会知道它到处都是公地。所以克拉珀姆公地、斯特里特姆公地、温布尔登公地等等。但关于肯宁顿的事情是，在所有的公地中，它是离伦敦城和威斯敏斯特最近的。在17世纪和18世纪的过程中，伦敦城和威斯敏斯特正在凝聚和结合，成为一个巨大的城市扩张区。因此，到了18世纪，肯宁顿公地正在成为来自威斯敏斯特的人们的地方
and the city are going to play sport. So you have the earliest recorded cricket match there is 1724, and it's London against Dartford, of course, the home of Mick Jagger, great cricket fan, so that's good to know. But it's also the home throughout the 18th century of a very famous sports club called the Gymnastic Society, which, despite its name, actually it organizes wrestling, but is best known as a football club. And in fact, is often described by football historians as the first football club to be organized as such on a kind of coherent basis. And there's another sport, isn't there, that's played there, which is the
和城市去进行体育运动。所以你有那里最早记录的板球比赛是1724年，那是伦敦对阵达特福德，当然，米克·贾格这也是个大板球迷的家乡，所以很高兴知道这一点。但它也是整个18世纪一个非常著名的体育俱乐部“体操协会”的所在地，尽管它的名字叫体操协会，但实际上它组织摔跤，但最著名的身份是一个足球俱乐部。事实上，足球历史学家经常将其描述为以某种连贯的基础组织起来的第一个足球俱乐部。还有另一项运动，不是吗，在那里举行，这是
regular encounters between criminals and the hangman. Yes. Isn't that right? Yeah, and this is kind of viewed as, I mean, it's not exactly a sport, but it's certainly an entertainment similar to sport. But if you think about a spectrum, Tom, of public spectacles, and cricket is at one end, and, you know, bull baiting or cockfighting is at the other, public executions do kind of sit on that spectrum a bit because they're big spectacles and there's lots of hawkers and people selling pies and kids go and all of this. So it is part of that world. Yes. And it means that the place where the gallows is situated is very strongly associated with public assemblies and people having fun. And the gallows stands on what today is St. Mark's Church directly outside what is now the Oval Tube Station on one side. And on the other side, Goldhanger Towers.
罪犯和刽子手之间的定期遭遇。是的。不是吗？是的，这被视为一种，我的意思，它不完全是一项运动，但它肯定是一种类似于体育的娱乐。但如果你想想一个光谱，汤姆，公众奇观，板球是一端，你知道的，斗牛或斗鸡在另一端，公开处决确实有点落在这个光谱上，因为它们是盛大的奇观，有很多小贩和卖馅饼的人，孩子们去所有这些。所以它是那个世界的一部分。是的。这意味着绞刑架所在的地方与公众集会和人们玩乐有很强的联系。绞刑架矗立在如今的圣马克教堂上，就在现在椭圆地铁站外的一侧。而在另一侧，戈德汉姆塔。
Yeah, the offices of our production company. Our production company, they would have been able to look out of the window and watch people being hanged. Yeah. So it would have been great fun. Whereas now Theo can watch us executing history on Zoom or whatever. Very good. So it's basically the South London equivalent of Tyburn Hill, what's now Marble Arch. And the most celebrated high women to be hanged there do have something of the status of great sporting heroes.
是的，我们制作公司的办公室。我们的制作公司，他们本可以透过窗户看着人们被绞死。是的。所以这会很有趣。而现在西奥可以看我们在Zoom或其他地方执行历史。非常好。所以它基本上是泰本山（现在的马大拱门）的南伦敦等价物。在那里被绞死的最大牌的女强盗确实具有伟大体育英雄的地位。
You know, there are people who display great charisma, great self-confidence, great self-control. And the most famous of all is a guy called Jerry Abashore who was very notorious highwayman. absolute lad who is hanged there in 1795. And so someone records his progress to the gallows, a bit like they're describing, I don't know, a batsman going to the Wicked or something. He kept up an incessant conversation with the persons who rode beside the car, frequently laughing and nodding to others of his acquaintances, whom he perceived in the crowd, which was immense. So you can imagine him kind of pointing to them and giving thumbs up. And then after his death, he's hung in chains on a gibbet on Wimbledon Common.
你知道，有些人表现出极大的魅力，极大的自信，极大的自我控制。其中最著名的是一个叫杰里·阿巴肖尔的家伙，他是一个非常臭名昭著的路霸。绝对是个小伙子，1895年在那儿被绞死。所以有人记录了他走向绞刑架的过程，有点像他们在描述，我不知道，一个击球手走向三柱门什么的。他与骑在车旁的人保持着不间断的对话，经常对人群中他发现的熟人大笑和点头，人群太巨大了。所以你可以想象他指着他们并竖起大拇指。死后，他在温布尔登公地的一个绞刑架上被链子挂着，
so he's the last hireman to suffer this fate, and it's meant to be a humiliation. But in a sense, it's a marker of his fame. This is someone who people wants to go and see even once he's dead. But sadly, for fans of public hangings, the age of executions as entertainment starting to pass. And the last execution on Kennington Common takes place in 1799. And this is partly for kind of squeamish, hand-winging, woke reasons. But it's also because Kennington Common. common is increasingly vanishing beneath brick. And so people start to worry that not only hangings
所以他是遭遇这种命运的最后一个强盗，这本意是一种羞辱。但在某种程度上，这是他名气的标志。这是一个即使他死了人们也想去看的人。但可悲的是，对于公开绞刑的粉丝来说，作为娱乐的处决时代正在过去。肯宁顿公地的最后一次处决发生在1799年。这部分是出于挑剔的、手足无措的、“觉醒”的原因。但这也是因为肯宁顿公地。公地正日益消失在砖块之下。因此人们开始担心不仅是绞刑
but also opportunities to do wrestling and football and cricket and so on will vanish completely from this great public area of congregation for people from London. And this is why local businessmen spot an opportunity. So in March 1845, a consortium headed by a chemist from Brixton Hill, I'm proud to say, where I live. And this is a guy called William Houghton. They buy the lease for a new cricket ground on Kennington Common, and they call it the oval because there is a river called the Ephra, which is now completely culverted and covered up, but it curves. And so the oval is situated in that curve, and it forms an oval. It's not a great area, very, very smelly. So there's a report that it's in a most ruinous
而且摔跤、足球和板球等活动的机会也将从这个伦敦人聚会的伟大公共区域完全消失。这就是当地商人发现商机的原因。因此，在1845年3月，由布里克斯顿山的一位药剂师领导的一个财团，我很自豪地说，我住在那里。这是一个叫威廉·霍顿的人。他们购买了肯宁顿公地新板球场的租约，他们称之为椭圆球场（Oval），因为有一条名为埃夫拉的河流，现在完全被涵洞化并覆盖了，但它是弯曲的。因此，椭圆球场就坐落在这个弯曲处，形成了一个椭圆形。这不是一个好地方，非常非常臭。因此有报道称它处于最破烂的
condition and from the effluvium arising from decayed vegetables, a nuisance and a source of ill health. So they have to bring in 10,000 lumps of turf from Tootin Common kind of cover up this rotting vegetation. And the other problem with the Oval is that Houghton, this chemist from Brixton Hill, turns out to be involved in all kinds of dodgy real estate deals. And this is the guy who books the pedestrianism event, Manx's for great feat, makes lots of money, but not enough. And by 1854, he's in such financial problems that he essentially has to hand the consortium over to his brother. And the following year, he declares bankruptcy. And the risk is that his financial misadventures will drag down the Oval. It will have to be sold off to developers.
状况，并且由于腐烂蔬菜产生的气味，是一种滋扰和健康不良的来源。所以他们不得不从图丁公地运来10,000块草皮来掩盖这些腐烂的植被。椭圆球场的另一个问题是，来自布里克斯顿山的药剂师霍顿原来参与了各种不正当的房地产交易。这家伙预定了步行竞走活动，曼克斯的壮举，赚了很多钱，但还不够。到了1854年，他陷入了巨大的财务困境，基本上不得不把财团交给他弟弟。第二年，他宣布破产。风险在于他的金融倒霉事会拖垮椭圆球场。它将不得不被卖给开发商。
And there will be nowhere for people, you know, in Kennington to have sport at all. And that's a very familiar story to anybody who follows sport today. You know, I mean, to our American listeners, you know, the way that NFL franchises move from city to city and there's always arguments about the stadiums and whatnot. So what happens? So it doesn't get sold off. Local enthusiasts, again, a very familiar story, you know, effectively local fans step in to save the ground. Yeah, so these are members of what's called the Surrey Club, and these are basically the people who organise cricket clubs across the county of Surrey, which Kennington is a part of. And in 1845, so that's the same year that Houghton had set up the Oval, a hundred of these members from these various cricket clubs meet in a pub around the corner from the Oval. And the Sunday Times reports what happened, that it was proposed to form a cricket club for the county of Surrey, the objects of which would mainly be to seek out and to bring together the playing strength of the county with a view of placing Surrey in the prominent position it had for many years in days long since past held in the cricket world.
肯宁顿的人们将无处进行体育运动。这对于任何关注今天体育运动的人来说是一个非常熟悉的故事。你知道，我的意思是，对于我们的美国听众来说，NFL特许经营权从一个城市转移到另一个城市的方式，总是存在关于体育场等的争论。那么发生了什么？所以它没有被卖掉。当地的爱好者，又是一个非常熟悉的故事，你知道，当地的球迷有效地介入拯救了球场。是的，这些是所谓的萨里俱乐部的成员，这些基本上是在萨里郡各地组织板球俱乐部的人，肯宁顿是其中的一部分。1845年，也就是霍顿建立椭圆球场的同年，来自这些不同板球俱乐部的100名成员在椭圆球场拐角处的一家酒吧里见面。星期日泰报报道了发生的事情，提议为萨里郡成立一个板球俱乐部，其目的主要是寻找和汇集该郡的比赛实力，以期将萨里恢复到多年前在板球界曾经拥有的显赫地位。
So this is a kind of classic Victorian manoeuvre. You've got sports enthusiasts meeting in pubs, founding clubs, drawing up rules. And as with the guys who meet to draw up the FA, football association, yeah. Yeah. So with these guys meeting in the pub round from the Oval, it's not just that they set up a cricket club for Surrey. In the long run, Surrey will become part of a broader championship, a county championship. So counties playing cricket across England, which is still going strong to this day. So this is the kind of the popular end of sport, the sense of local fans, local organizers,
所以这是一种典型的维多利亚时代的策略。你有体育爱好者在酒吧见面，建立俱乐部，制定规则。就像那些见面起草FA（足球协会）的人一样，对，是的。所以随着这些人在椭圆球场附近的酒吧见面，这不仅是他们为萨里成立了一个板球俱乐部。从长远来看，萨里将成为更广泛的锦标赛的一部分，即郡锦标赛。因此萨里在英格兰各地进行板球比赛，至今仍然强劲。所以这是体育的流行端，当地球迷、当地组织者的感觉，
people who have a commitment to their local club. But there is also something that will also be very familiar to people who follow sport today, which is the engagement of those who are very, very well connected, very rich, and in lots of cases, thinking of certain football clubs today, actually royal. So in the case of the Oval, back in the mid-Victorian period, I mean, it couldn't be more Victorian, because the person who also steps in to save the Oval is none other than the husband of Queen Victoria, Prince Albert. And he is acting on behalf of the young Prince of Wales, so the future Edward the 7th, who is the landlord of the Oval, ultimately. And Prince Albert refuses to allow the Oval to be sold to developers. And he gives his backing to
对当地俱乐部有承诺的人。但也有一些东西对于今天关注体育运动的人来说也非常熟悉，那就是那些人脉非常广、非常富有的人的参与，在很多情况下，想到今天的某些足球俱乐部，实际上是皇室。所以在椭圆球场的案例中，回到维多利亚中期，我的意思是，它不可能更维多利亚了，因为也介入拯救椭圆球场的人不是别人，正是维多利亚女王的丈夫，阿尔伯特亲王。他代表年轻的威尔士亲王行事，也就是最终的椭圆球场房东，未来的爱德华七世。阿尔伯特亲王拒绝允许将椭圆球场卖给开发商。他支持
the Surrey Committee. And it's this that enables them in 1845 when it looks as though the Oval will have to be sold to step in and take over control of the ground. And is this because the future Edward the seventh is a big cricket fan? I mean, Prince Albert, presumably, he doesn't give a damn about cricket. No, he doesn't particularly, and nor does Prince Albert. But I think they see it as Prince Albert's a great enthusiast for manliness and outdoor activities and all that kind of thing. And he thinks that it would be good for the working masses to have this ground. Fresh air. Yeah. And to this day, the Prince of Wales is the Oval's landlord. So Prince William is the landlord of the Oval, even though obviously he'd rather, I think, be the landlord of
萨里委员会。正是这一点使他们在1845年椭圆球场看似必须出售时能够介入并接管对该球场的控制权。这是因为未来的爱德华七世是一个板球大球迷吗？我的意思，阿尔伯特亲王，大概，他根本不在乎板球。不，他并不是特别在乎，阿尔伯特亲王也不在乎。但我认为他们认为这是阿尔伯特亲王对男子气概和户外活动以及所有这类事情的极大热情。他认为工作群众拥有这个球场会很好。新鲜空气。是的。时至今日，威尔士亲王依然是椭圆球场的房东。所以威廉王子是椭圆球场的房东，尽管显然他认为他宁愿成为维拉公园的房东，而不是椭圆球场。其实他对足球了解很多。曾对有过采访。汤姆，我敢说，我认为他比你了解得稍微多一点。好吧，他在阿斯顿维拉的Reddit群组和球迷论坛等地方闲逛。是吗？是的，他确实。他非常非常渊博。
Villa Park than the Oval. He knows a lot about football, actually. There was an interview with him. Tom, dare I say, I think he knows a tiny bit more than you do. Well, he hangs out on Aston Villa kind of Reddit groups and fan forums and so on. Does he? Yeah, he does. He's very, very knowledgeable.
对。我想他对板球不那么感兴趣，尽管萨里的徽章是三根羽毛，那是威尔士亲王的徽章，最终来自黑太子他在克雷西战役中的伟大壮举。所以拯救椭圆球场，甚至椭圆球场的创建，退一步看，你可以看到它是更广泛过程的一部分，不是吗？不仅在体育方面，实际上在维多利亚时代的社会和休闲生活普遍方面，
Right. I think less interested in cricket, although the badge of Surrey is the three feathers, that is the badge of the Prince of Wales, which ultimately comes from the Black Prince and his great feat at the Battle of Cressy. So the saving of the Oval, and indeed the creation of the Oval at all, You could see sort of stepping back. It's part of a wider process, isn't it? Not just in sport, actually, between Victorian social and leisure life generally,
这全关于规范化、结构化、专业化、驯服事物的颠覆性能量，并将其精简并全部分类。一旦你有了场地和俱乐部，我的意思是，维多利亚人喜欢俱乐部，但一旦他们有了俱乐部，他们就会喜欢联赛，不是吗？或者杯赛。我们现在对此非常熟悉，并且认为理所当然。
which is all about codifying, structuring, professionalising, kind of taming the disruptive energies of things and sort of streamlining them and sorting them all out. And once you've got grounds and you've got clubs, I mean, the Victorians love a club, but once they've got clubs, they then love a league, don't they? Or a cup competition. We're very familiar with that now, and we take it for granted.
但他们基本上发明了那个模式。是的，一旦你有了联赛和杯赛，这就不仅仅是安排一场比赛或体育赛事的问题了。你可以有某种持续的收入流，因为你有一场接一场接一场的比赛，这一切都是基于此的。对。而今天，这就是职业体育完全依赖的基础设施。正如你所说，我们认为理所当然。但对于19世纪下半叶的维多利亚时代体育企业家来说，我的意思是，这就像 stumbled on a gold mine。以前从来没有人想过这样做。
But they basically invent that model. Yes, because once you have leagues and cups, it's not just a matter of arranging one-off matches or sporting events. You can have kind of continuous income flow because you have match after match after match and it's all kind of predicated. Right. And this today is the infrastructure that professional sport completely depends upon. And as you say, we take it for granted. But to Victorian sports entrepreneurs in the second half of the 19th century, I mean, it's like stumbling on a gold mine. No one had ever thought of doing this before.
没有。突然他们想，太棒了。我们可以在这里赚这么多钱。对。所以我认为椭圆球场的管理者并不令人惊讶，它实际上是第一个把自己变成企业的伟大体育场，比贵族们的场地洛德球场（Lords）更公开得多。他们开辟道路并不令人惊讶。
No. And suddenly they're thinking, brilliant. We can just make so much money here. Right. And so I think it's not surprising that the administrators at the Oval, which effectively is the first great sports ground to have transformed itself into a business, so much more overtly say than Lords, which is the posh people's ground. It's not surprising that they blaze the path.
特别有一个人以一种精疲力竭的精力和热情表现出这一点，看起来几乎有点典型的维多利亚时代。这是一个叫查尔斯·W·奥尔科克（Charles W. Alcock）的家伙。他不可能更维多利亚了。他留着胡子。他系着领带。他有着由公立学校体育磨练出来的宽阔肩膀。考虑他的职业生涯基本上让人筋疲力尽，我想。
And there is one person in particular who does this with a kind of exhausting display of energy and enthusiasm, it seems almost kind of stereotypically Victorian. And this is a guy called Charles W. Orcock. He couldn't be more Victorian. He has a mustache. He has a cravat. He's got kind of great shoulders honed by sport at public school. And it's basically just exhausting to contemplate his career, I think.
是的，这太不可思议了。他是工业家儿子的经典例子，他去私立学校，最终进入了一个与你那双手粗糙的父亲完全不同的领域。所以他出生在桑德兰，就像另一个伟大的足球爱好者乔纳森·威尔逊（节目之友）一样。是的。
Yeah, it's incredible. He is the classic example of an industrialist son who goes to a private school and ends up in a completely different sphere from. you know, his horny-handed father. So he's born in Sunderland, like that other great football enthusiast, Jonathan Wilson, a friend of the show. Yeah.
他去了哈罗公学，在哈罗，他踢足球和板球，他绝对喜欢它。他的基本感觉是，当他离开公立学校时，他为什么要放弃体育？他想继续下去。所以他以体育记者的身份谋生，
And he goes to Harrow, and at Harrow, he plays football and cricket, and he absolutely loves it. And his basic feeling is when he leaves his public school, why should he have to give up sport? He wants to carry on with it. So he makes a living as a sports journalist,
报道足球、报道板球、报道田径。但事实证明，他真正的天才在于体育，体育行政管理。所以在1870年，他不仅成为FA（足球协会）的秘书，还成为财务主管。两年后，他成为总部设在椭圆球场的萨里郡板球俱乐部的秘书。所以他不仅喜欢体育。他喜欢委员会会议。他确实喜欢。他喜欢组织比赛然后去参加比赛。
covering football, covering cricket, covering athletics. But it turns out his real genius is for sports, Sports Administration. So in 1870, he becomes not just the secretary, but the treasurer of the FA, the Football Association. And then two years later, he becomes secretary of Surrey County Cricket Club, which is based at the Oval. So he doesn't just like sport. He loves committee meetings. He does. He does. And he loves to organise fixtures and then to play in them.
对。所以他两全其美。关键是，你会赞同这一点的，多米尼克，他真正的比赛，即使他某种程度上以椭圆球场为基地，不是板球，而是足球。他是足球历史上非常著名的人物。极其著名。当你阅读足球的早期历史时，到处都是他。他在每一页上。是的。所以在1863年，他创立了一支最初到处都是老哈罗公学男生的队伍。
Right. So he has the best of both worlds. And the thing is, you'd approve of this, Dominic, his real game, even though he's kind of based at the Oval, isn't cricket, but football. And he's a very famous figure in the history of football. Enormously famous. When you read the early history of football, he's everywhere. He's kind of in every page. Yes. So in 1863, he found a side that to begin with is full of old Horovians.
所以Alcock来自他的公立学校的伙伴叫流浪者队（The Wanderers）。他们玩的是所谓的组合游戏，在其中你实际上是在传球而不仅仅是带球。对。你知道，这也是展望未来。在1869年，Alcock让他们在椭圆球场安顿下来。所以椭圆球场成了他们的家。所以你在夏天打板球，然后在冬天踢足球。
So Alcox chums from his public school called The Wanderers. And they play what is called the combination game in which you actually pass the ball rather than just dribbling it. Right. You know, and this again is looking forward to the future. And in 1869, Alcock sets them up at the Oval. So the Oval becomes their home. So you play cricket through the summer and then you play football through the winter.
在1872年，他为足球协会设立了一个杯赛，即足总杯（FA Cup）。不可避免地，他安排决赛在椭圆球场举行。同样不可避免的是，他担任球队队长，流浪者队赢了。是的，当然他们赢了。所以他们以1-0获胜，Alcock实际上进了一个球，但它被取消了，因为有手球。哦，不。所以某种程度上可以说是VAR的原型介入并破坏了事情。对。流浪者队在1873年也继续赢得足总杯，然后在1876年、1877年和1878年连续几年获胜，这三场连续的胜利都是在椭圆球场赢得的。事实上，椭圆球场一共举办了19场足总杯决赛，
And in 1872, he institutes a cup competition for the Football Association, the FAA Cup. And inevitably, he arranges for the final to be held at the Oval. And also inevitably, he captains the team and the World. wanderers win. Yeah, of course they do. So they win 1-0 and Alcock had actually scored a goal but it gets disqualified because they'd been a handball. Oh no. So kind of prototype for VAR I guess kicking in and spoiling things. Right. And the Wanderers go on to win the FAA Cup in 1873 as well and then again they win in consecutive years in 1876, 1877 and 78 and all three of those consecutive victories are one at the Oval. And in fact, the Oval stages 19 FAA Cup finals in
对我们俩都有趣。所以这包括阿斯顿维拉在1887年赢得的足总杯第一场胜利，两年后的1889年，多米尼克，狼队首次出现在足总杯决赛中。是的，第一次出现，我们没有赢。我们以0-3输给了普雷斯顿。非常令人失望。非常悲伤。但也有国际体育，对吧？
all and interest to both of us. So this includes the first victory won by Ashton Villa in the FA Cup in 1887 and then two years later in 1889, Dominic, Wolves' first appearance in an FA Cup final. Yeah, first appearance, we didn't win. We lost 3-0 to Preston. Very disappointing. Very sad. But also international sports, right?
你知道，我们现在对国际体育的概念习以为常，但你可以说它是被这个叫Alcock的家伙发明的。是的。所以在1879年，你知道，他设立了足总杯，然后他想，好吧，我们为什么不让英格兰对阵苏格兰呢？比赛当然在椭圆球场举行。而且当然，Alcock担任英格兰队长。结果是1比1平局。
You know, we're so used to the idea of international sport now, but you could argue it was invented by this Blake Alcock. Yes. So in 1879, you know, he's set up the FA Cup and then he thinks, well, well, why don't we get England to play Scotland? And the match is held, of course, at the Oval. And of course, all cocked captains England. And the result is a one-all draw.
对。可悲的是，这场比赛没有被国际足联认可，因为苏格兰队是由住在伦敦的苏格兰人组成的。哦。这包括首相的儿子格莱斯顿。真的吗？但他们没有真正来自苏格兰的人，因为对他们来说一路南下似乎太远了。
Right. Sadly, this match isn't recognised by FIFA because the Scottish team is drawn from Scotsman living in London. Oh. And this includes Gladstone, the Prime Minister's son. Really? But they don't have people actually from Scotland because it seems as being too far for them to come all the way down.
对。这就是为什么它不被认可。所以这真是一个遗憾。我们之前谈到的另一项运动是橄榄球。他还组织了椭圆球场的第一场橄榄球国际比赛，依然是英格兰对苏格兰，1872年。是的，我的意思是，这太惊人了。然后，当然，还有板球。同样不可避免的是，Alcock是幕后策划英格兰和澳大利亚之间国际测试赛的主脑。
Right. So that's why it's not recognised. So that's a great shame. There's one other sport we talked about earlier, which was rugby. He also organises the first rugby international as well at the Oval, England, Scotland again, 1872. Yeah, I mean, it's just astonishing. And then, of course, there is cricket. And inevitably, again, it's Alcock who's the presiding genius behind setting up international test matches between England and Australia.
这就是日后孕育出骨灰的系列比赛。所以Alcock，他在足球方面显然达到了国际水准，板球方面稍逊。他确实打过郡板球，但没有为英格兰效力。但他通过成为英格兰第一个认识到国际板球可能有多大赚钱潜力的人来弥补这一点。所以国际板球已经在澳大利亚打过了。英格兰也在那里对阵过澳大利亚。但英格兰的人觉得，哦，我的意思是，我们超越了这个。
And this is the series of matches that in due course will give birth to the ashes. So Orcock, he's clearly of international standard of football, less so at cricket. He does play county cricket, but doesn't play for England. But he makes up for this by being the first person in England to recognise how much money there might be in international cricket. So international cricket has been played in Australia. England has played Australia there. But people in England think, oh, I mean, we're above this.
我的意思是，这有点低俗。这是一场浮华的奇观。我们才不理会它。但Alcock认识到，如果它能在澳大利亚赚钱，那为什么不在英格兰呢？所以在1880年，他设法在椭圆球场举办了在英格兰举行的第一场测试赛。这是一次巨大的成功。所以W·G·格雷斯，这个大胡子类型的体育明星，他得了一个世纪，英格兰赢了，比赛完全爆满。所以，哗啦啦。
I mean, it's a kind of vulgar. It's a showy spectacle. We're not going to bother with it. But Alcock recognises that if it can make money in Australia, then why not in England? So in 1880, he manages to stage the first test match to be played in England at the Oval. And it's a tremendous success. So WG Grace, this great bearded kind of sports star, he scores a century, England win, and the match is a complete sellout. So Caching.
然后在1882年，澳大利亚人回来了。这是一场臭名昭著的英格兰失利（如果你是澳大利亚听众，则是辉煌的胜利），它激发了体育时报上的讣告。这又是一次巨大的体育盛会。这次的英雄是一个名叫弗雷德·斯波福斯（Fred Spoffoth）的澳大利亚人，他留着绝对壮观的澳大利亚快球手胡须，垂在下巴下方。
And then in 1882, the Australians come back. And this is the notorious England defeat, or glorious, if you're an Australian listener, that inspires the obituary in sporting times. And again, it's a tremendous sporting occasion. And the hero this time is an Australian called Fred Spoffoth, who has an absolutely magnificent Australian fast bowler's moustache kind of drooping down past his chin.
太棒了，是的。他被称为恶魔。从那时起，所有快球手都被称为恶魔。他拿下了14个三柱门，对于不了解板球的人来说，这非常非常棒，因为你能拿下的最大数量是20个。
Excellent, yeah. He's called the demon. So from that point on, all fast bowlers are called demons. He takes 14 wickets, which for people who don't know about cricket is very, very good, because the maximum you can take is 20.
英格兰非常非常险些输掉。再次，有点像曼克斯的步行竞走壮举，球场完全满了，外面的街道人头攒动，人们坐在那里咬着伞柄嚼。太紧张了。人们心脏病发作，所有这类事情。这是一次巨大的成功。我认为像那样的比赛，像足总杯、第一场橄榄球国际比赛这样的比赛，它们围绕着这些体育赛事建立了一种浪漫主义，
England lose very, very narrowly. And again, a bit like with Max's feet of pedestrianism, the ground is absolutely full, streets outside are heaving, people sit there chewing their way through umbrella handles. It's so tense. People have heart attacks, all that kind of thing. And it's an enormous success. And I think that match like that, matches like, you know, the FAA Cups, the first rugby international, they kind of establish a romance around these sporting events that in
至今仍是如此。这就是为什么，无论是骨灰还是其他什么，这是维多利亚时代的最伟大成就之一，他们建立的模板至今仍然激励着人们。是的，绝对的。步行竞走运动怎么了？这才是真正的问题。好吧，有趣的是，它在英国逐渐消失，但在19世纪下半叶的美国变得非常受欢迎。真的吗？是的，我猜因为在那里这是一件新鲜事。所以整个19世纪，纽约成为步行竞走运动的新伟大中心。然后到了19世纪末，它也渐渐消失了。但我认为如果有任何人，你知道，任何体育管理者或参与体育媒体的人
years to this day. And that's why, you know, whether it's the ashes or whatever, it's one of the great achievements of the Victorian era that they established templates that people still are inspired by to this day. Yeah, absolutely. What happened to pedestrianism? That's the real question. Well, what's interesting is that it fades out in Britain, but it becomes very popular in the second half of the 19th century in America. Really? Yeah, I guess because there it's something novel. So right the way through the 19th century, New York becomes the new great center for pedestrianism. And then at the end of the 19th century, it fades away too. But I think if there's anyone, you know, any sports administrators or involved in sports media
听这个，步行竞走运动的复兴早就该发生了。对。具有讽刺意味的是，今天美国有大片大片的地方，如果你走在街上，你知道，警察会把车停下来。回来。以未开车为由逮捕你。美国听众，你们为什么不重新发现你们对步行竞走的爱呢？整理好你们自己。所以汤姆，这不是本周唯一的体育播客，对吧？因为我们将在周 Donnerstag 深入研究体育历史。你想告诉
listening to this, a revival of pedestrianism is long overdue. Right. The irony that today there are great swathes of the United States where if you walk down the street, you know, the police will pull over. Come back. Arrest you for not driving. Why don't you rediscover your love of pedestrianism, America? listeners. Sort yourselves out. So Tom, this is not the only sporting podcast of the week, is it? Because we'll be delving back into sporting history on Thursday. Do you want to tell
人们关于这一切吗？是的。所以在那个节目中，我们将看的不是团队运动，而是拳击。我们将专门研究有史以来最著名、非凡和最具影响力的体育比赛之一。这是一场拳击比赛，于1860年在汉普郡农村的一个田野里举行，介于英格兰和美国的 rival 冠军之间。多米尼克，如果人们想立刻收听那个节目，有什么方法可以做到吗？有的，因为有点像维多利亚时代的公立学校协会，我们成立了自己的体育俱乐部。它被称为“历史的其余部分俱乐部”，你可以在therestis history.com注册，
people all about that? Yeah. So in that show, we'll be looking not at a team sport, but at boxing. And we'll be looking specifically at one of the most celebrated, extraordinary and influential sporting contests of all time. And it's a boxing match that is held in a field in rural Hampshire in 1860 between the rival champions of England and America. And Dominic, if people want to tune into that right away, is there a way they can do that? There is, because rather like a Victorian public school association, we've started our own sporting club. It's called The Rest Is History Club, and you can sign up at the rest is history.com,
你将获得各种好处。其中一个好处就是你可以立刻听到那一集。所以无论如何不要错过它。绝对的。好吧，汤姆，那是一个步行的……那是一个积极的步行集。是的，一个步行表现
and you get all kinds of benefits. And one of those benefits is you can hear that episode right away. So do not miss it under any circumstances. Absolutely. Well, Tom, that was a pedestrian That was a positively pedestrian episode. Yeah, a pedestrian performance
不愧是理查德·曼克斯本人。非常感谢。伴随着那个重磅炸弹，我们下次再见，观看世纪之战。再见。再见。嗨。
Worthy of Richard Manx himself. Thank you very much. And on that, Bomber shell, we will see you for the fight of the century next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Hi.
嗨。我是威廉·德林普尔。再次来自帝国（Empire），另一个戈德汉姆播客。这是我们最近关于创造现代亚洲的五次分治的系列节目的片段。这非常感人。斯帕什从村子里捡了一些鹅卵石，他把它们做成首饰，家族传家宝，代代相传。
Hi. It's William Drimple here. again from Empire, another Goldhanger podcast. Here's the clip from our recent series on the five partitions that created modern Asia. And it was deeply emotional. Sparsh picked up some pebbles from the village, which he made into jewelry, family heirloons, for his family going down the generations.
因为他总是在说，你知道，我的家庭没有档案等等。我们在分治中失去了一切。贝拉没有任何东西能展示我们来自哪里。所以他想从贝拉捡起一些东西，把它做成下一代的传家宝，你知道，三、四代人之后，
Because he was always saying, you know, my family doesn't have archives, etc. We lost everything in partition. And there's nothing that we have from Beela to show where we came from. But so he wanted to pick up something from Beela and make it into airlines for the next generations, you know, three, four generations from now,
他们仍然会随身带着一块贝拉，即使，你知道，印度和帕基斯坦之间的关系再次恶化。并且，你知道，即使他的孩子永远不能访问贝拉，他们也会永远随身带着一块贝拉。这种与大地的联系，他们称之为印度的Dharthi，Zamin是乌尔都语，意思完全一样。但这远不止是土地。它是你是谁，你从哪里长大，你的祖先从哪里长大。
they'll still have a piece of Bela with them, even if, you know, the relationship between India and Pakistan worsens again. And, you know, even if his kids can never visit Bela, they'll always have a piece of Bela with them. This connection with Earth, Dherty, you know, they call it Dharthi in India, and Zamin is the Udu word for exactly the same thing. But it is much more than just the earth. It is who you are, where you have grown from, where your forebears have grown. from. And the number of people I know who have been lucky enough to travel across the border, and I count myself as one, who find it impossible to leave without a scoop of Earth. And I have one too. You know, in Lahore, picked up a handful of Earth and brought it back with me.
我知道有许多人有幸穿过边界，我把自己算作其中之一，他们发现离开时不可能不带上一铲泥土。我也有一个。你知道，在拉合尔，捡了一把泥土并把它带回了我。
Because I thought, you know, this is the stuff my grandfather used to walk on. To hear the full series, just search Empire wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为我想，你知道，这是我爷爷曾经走过的东西。要收听完整的系列，只需在您获取播客的任何地方搜索Empire。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子发表评论。